il est vrai que depuis plus d'un an
maintenant on est confronté à un double
langage c'est un peu le langage du
pompiers incendiaires
c'est à dire le on a eu droit à des
prises de parole gouvernemental plus que
maladroite qui a encouragé une
crispation vraiment vraiment forte de
vis à vis de la population et puis en
face à ceux réponse qu'on avait c'était
bien allez on envoie les régiments de
policiers qui vont nous régler tout ça
c'est pour moi et pas que pour moi du
reste un c'est pas raisonnable c'est
tout simplement pas raisonnable ni
cohérent on ne peut pas régler cette
problématique sociale elle est profonde
uniquement en y répondant par la force
en tout cas par la fonction publique par
les policiers qui je le rappelle sont
touchés par toutes les réformes c'est et
souligné effectivement les policiers de
base et même de grade intermédiaires je
voudrais un petit peu à part une forme
de caste policière qui l est est
indépendante de ce qui concerne de
toutes les préoccupations de base mais
il ya véritablement une problématique de
je dirais de discours et de philosophie
d'emploi c'est ça aussi surtout qu'il
faut parler quelle qu'est ce que l'on
veut faire de la police dans ce pays
aujourd'hui c'est un vrai débat quelle
est la philosophie d'emploi on à la
police qu'on mérite un globalement
quelque part un dès lors que l'on met en
place un pouvoir qui a cette attitude là
faut pas s'en plaindre quand vous dites
on à la police qu'on mérite ça veut dire
que la population mairie pour que le
gouvernement mais c'est un peu d eux
même chose c'est un peu c'est un peu des
deux si vous dès lors que vous mettez en
place des gouvernants qui tiennent un
discours très radicale ce que j'ai 35
ans de police derrière moi j'ai eu 30 50
points à peu près faire l'économie d'une
année ou deux j'ai vu une succession
police de pardon de politique
sécuritaire qui était aussi inopérantes
les unes que les autres et il fallait
régulièrement je dirais tenir la société
uniquement par le bon vouloir et la
bonne volonté des fonctionnaires de
terrain à un moment donné ce système ne
tient plus parce que vous ne savez plus
de toute façon quel est le sens de votre
métier et ça rejoint le débat qu'on va
évoquer sur des suicides et le malade
dans la police dès lors que vous ne
savez plus quel est le sens de ce que
vous faites est nécessairement semaines
assure du mal est donc des dépressions
et des suicides sachant qu'il ya aussi
pas mal de dépression et puis le rapport
avec la citoyenneté avec la population
lorsque vous avez des policiers enfin
des politiques pardon qui vont de la
police de proximité qui ré inventé l'eau
tiède à une police de résultats
hystérique et ensuite à une police
absolument
une politique sécuritaire qui est
indéchiffrable plus personne n'y
comprend rien et des policiers comme de
la citoyenneté faut écouter ce que
veulent les gens en termes de politiques
mentent pas ce qui est plus de police y
compris ce que l'on appelle les gilet
jaune demande pas ça du tout ils
demandent au contraire une police avec
laquelle on puisse dialoguer qu'ils
soient des vrais partenaires et pas
simplement des uniformes bleus
[Musique]